double assiette ce professeur de droit
et spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines
douglas yates bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors ce
rejet de la cour suprême de pennsylvanie
est ce qu'elle met un terme aux espoirs
de donald trump de remporter cette
élection à ses espoirs mais en réalité
elle a bien du tout c'est pas très
juridique est donc maintenant ils
menacent d autres choses qu'il ne
précise pas mais peut-être et les
actions par sa base il ya beaucoup de
militantes et vie des lentilles et
toutes choses sont possibles mais pour
l'instant le recours aux creux au procès
judiciaire semble une échec en
pennsylvanie par exemple ce sont des
juges républicaine et un des ses juges
et tire une nomination de l'entrant donc
l'idée que les juges républicaine loyaux
présidente ventes bouleversé les
élections ne semble pas produit et
est-ce que donald trump est encore
soutenue par les cadres des républicains
dans son combat pour faire invalider
l'élection
oui à maintenant l'enjeu pour le premier
républicaine au niveau national c'est le
sénat il y a deux sièges dans giorgi qui
sont en jeu il est en élection spéciale
et tout le premier rideau mais qu'un
sarko centre ans et risque de perdre ses
sièges au sénat et donc le majorité donc
oui pour l'instant lemagit de donneurs
prend avec
comme les caennais face au mans sont
base est assez importante que
l'établissement républicains continuent
à le soutenir
très peu de républicains ont avoué qu'il
a peur de les élections mais si les
républicains perdre le géologie et le
sénat là un bavoir l'établissement alors
dans le même temps que je baille donne a
procédé à ses premières nominations il a
été autorisé par donald trump à recevoir
les briefings quotidiens des services de
renseignement est ce que ces faits
démontrent que la transition est bel et
bien lancée oui la préparation de la
nouvelle administration est en marche
bridge a sélectionné un parti de son
cabinet ça veut dire ses ministres notre
cercle terrain et spécialement dans le
politique étrangère mais à la grosse
partie des nominations en fait pour le
présidente les positions de plus
importantes exige une faute dans le
scénar donc si les démocrates perdent
les sonates ces nominations sera en
danger alors donald trump a admis qu'il
quitterait la maison blanche le 20
janvier si joe biden était
officiellement reconnu vainqueur
est-ce que cela met fin à un risque d'un
embrasement du pays
non donnant sur 30
maintenant je le krach de lever de
centre pour chaque campagne pour
rembourser sa dette et amassé une
fortune pour lancer une nouvelle gamme
aidé en montrant aussi se souder avec sa
base avec les théories de conspiration
dans lequel l'élection était volé donc
le en fait quitté la maison blanche veut
maison blanche peut survivre sa
stratégie alors qu'un pourrait lancer
pour une nouvelle campagne est passé
quatre ans sans les responsabilités
d'une présidence alors il ya aussi cette
affaire de l'assassinât en iran du chef
du programme nucléaire
il aurait été validé par washington
est ce la preuve que donald trump va
pratiquer une sorte de politique de la
terre brûlée avant l'ascension de joe
biden au pouvoir jouer dans ces derniers
en juin il continuait à nominer les gens
nos positions de pardonner ses anciens
collabos collaborateurs et se souder ses
rapports avec les alliés dont il s'est
fait et petit le mans dans le dossier
iranien avec les faucons dans
l'établissement de défense et les ir
soufiane le gouvernement netanyahu merci
beaucoup
douglas yates pour votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines